the plot for a potential new Stargate
movie has been revealed and this video
is going to be my reaction to that
general plot line
and a few of the revelations as well
that apparently Bad Robot have got
planned welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi
TV and movie channel
[Music]
so once again if it's anything to do
with Stargate
um first and I am telling you what is
going on behind the Iron Curtain at
Amazon and the plans that have been put
in place for a potential new Stargate
movie
so I in the previous video told you the
general plot line I threw in a couple of
my thoughts along the way but in this
video I'm going to tell you exactly what
I think Point by point
so first of all the general plot line
it's very formulaic
um as far as I'm concerned there is
nothing in this video in this film idea
the bad robots put in that is
particularly clever it is simply a go to
a new world five ra ooh have a fight the
end now I don't actually have a major
problem with that I consider this to be
a popcorn movie and it is formulaic but
let's be honest most films and TV series
are you have a First Act a second act
and the third act something has to
happen in each of those phases and that
you know it's kind of what we expect
from a lot of movies particularly sort
of action movies now that's my other
point this comes across to me very much
as an action movie there's a lot of
battles and fights going on another
Point as well is that I'm going to say
that this comes across to me again in a
very formulaic way as very linked to the
original Stargate movie now I did drop
the bomb on you that they actually want
a Bad Robot are pushing for Kurt Russell
to appear as Jack O'Neill two L's one L
what do one L now that again harks
straight back to the original movie so I
have to ask the first question is this a
reboot is this a hybrid reboot are they
going to basically ignore what's
happened in the SG-1 and just at this as
a sequel to the original movie
well the way this seems to be set up
it's going to very much depend on what
we see in the SGC parts of the film so
when they're on the alien world that can
be one thing but what happens on the SGC
is going to tell us whether this is a
hard reboot or not if the SGC is now a
civilian operation quite a big operation
and we can assume that maybe is because
they talk about a civilian research team
being on the planet then we can assume
that sg1 still happened and that the SG
program has still been running and that
now it has evolved into something else
something that we've seen beyond what we
saw at the end of Stargate sg1 so the
Stargate program is now possibly known
to the public but at very least is a
much bigger and much wider project than
we saw at the end of the Stargate movie
but another possibility of that is that
they're just going to assume a 30-year
gap between the two and that actually
may be the sg1 thing happened maybe it
didn't
I've always thought you thought that
when they do this move it would be a
standalone movie and by that I mean
it doesn't you don't necessarily need to
know what happened in sg1 sgusga to
follow what happens in the film yes
you're going to have watched the
original Stargate film you're gonna have
to know what a Stargate is but as long
as you roughly remember the original
Stargate movie you will follow this film
but actually in fact if they do it right
it won't matter if you haven't seen the
original Stargate movie you'll still be
able to follow it
foreign
they will then throw in little Easter
eggs and little details that will then
bleed into the series but at the end of
the day this is going to be a 90 minute
movie they're going to want as wide an
audience as possible so don't expect a
direct continuation
off the series because that won't give
them the audience numbers they want
they're going to want new people to come
and watch this new people to Stargate
and they can't do that if it is a
straight up straight continuation so
that is what I'm assuming this is and
from the story plot that we're seeing
that seems to be the case so
yeah
civilian team yeah an SG team goes in
they get wiped out by the Jaffa now
that gives the SGC a reason to then
bring you an O'Neill now I think that's
going to be because they're going to be
assuming and what I've been told is
they've not seen the gold ruled in um
potentially years we haven't seen the
gold in a long time so they bring in
O'Neill because he is the number one
expert on fighting the gold
so I think they're going to maybe assume
that this is sort of like what you hear
about at the end of World War II when
the other the all the islands in the
Pacific and some Japanese soldiers were
like bought on the island and then
they're found in like the 60s and they
thought the war was still on
so I'm wondering if it's going to be a
bit like that that they assume this is
just a small pocket of Jaffa or maybe
even a gold walled
um that doesn't know the wars over there
doesn't know the system Lords of foul
that doesn't know everything that
happened in sg1 they've been hiding
there for some time and then we've
stumbled upon them so they send O'Neill
in the idea being made but to negotiate
and if necessary to kick their ass
but then we find out that the gold is
raw now how the bloody hell they're
writing ra into this
is gonna have to be intelligent if they
just go well he survived
that's going to be a cop-out they're
just bringing him back because it will
surprise everybody I mean the all I mean
to be fair if I can if I didn't know
this I'd have been going what the
um if they just go yeah he survived then
I I will have a problem with that
because we saw him take a nuclear weapon
to the face
so there's a problem but if they're
clever with it okay they bring back a
gold hey look sg1 brought back Anubis
loads of times and they never explained
it so
maybe they don't need to but hey gold
Raw
um then O'Neill and there's this whole
thing about ra uses the children as a
human shield now that then harks back to
the original Stargate thing plopped
mechanism for O'Neill the original Kurt
Russell O'Neill where his son shot
himself and died and that's why Jack
O'Neill is basically suicidal and that's
the character we see in the movie and he
basically redeems himself and you know
and by the end of it he doesn't want to
die
[Music]
um
I think that there does seem to be a
full circle thing going on here in the
the children
um are using the human shield there's a
plan in place that's going to start the
attack on ra um in space and on the
ground and
um but him using those children as a
human shield O'Neill then has to
sacrifice himself to I imagine protect
the children and signal that the attack
can start but saving the children in the
process now I think that is
basically like I said it's it's harking
back to the original story it's saying a
bit more about O'Neill and to be honest
it's a very simple but effective plot
mechanism but then apparently O'Neill
does die and we're gonna see General
Jack O'Neill die
it will be shocking and again if you
didn't know it was coming it would be
really shocking
from what I'm told about how the general
pitch went the idea being that the third
Act is then like say the big battle
sequence but it allows the actors that
are maybe been in the periphery because
O'Neill has been the lead actor the main
guy but the rest of the team to sort of
come through and it is those characters
and those actors that will then carry on
into whatever follows this movie so it
is those actors that we potentially then
see in any TV series or maybe second
movie or whatever
that kind of makes sense to me
um it's actually quite an interesting
mechanism to move beyond the film
so then there's a big battle sequence
ships in space on the ground
I'm actually very excited about by that
Prospect I want to see a BC 306 I want
to see an evolution of the Starships I
love a space battle a wicked
um and obviously we then get to see Rob
die I'm hoping they shoot him and then
they poke him and then they burn him and
they actually make sure he's dead this
time
so
yeah what do I think is the general
thing as I say it's formulaic it's not
very complicated I actually think that's
a good thing I think that generally
speaking I was quite afraid that they
would come in and try to do something
very clever
this could be part of a sort of a soft
reboot or a hard reboot it could be a
hybrid reboot but if they do this right
it doesn't really have to be either it
can be a standalone movie that it allows
a TV series to develop and at the end of
the day that's what we want we want the
TV series to come in with 10 20 30 hours
of Television that really develops the
story and we get to find out what's
happened over the last 15 years in
detail this movie will be a 19 minute
advert and Gateway into that as far as
I'm concerned if they do it right but
guys I'd love to know what exactly you
think about my feelings on this do you
think this is out like a good idea do
you think it sounds like a nice simple
story that they can pull off easily that
I like I said can lead into something
else or would you actually think it's a
formulating pile of crap and it's going
to be born it's just going to be and
stupid and actually bring it back raw
and bring it back Kurt Russell
maybe suggested they're actually going
for a hard reboot in I mean that the TV
series will be ignored is that a danger
with this plan I'd love to know exactly
what you think get into the comments if
you are new to the Channel please like
subscribe by the Bell notification and
if you want to support the channel even
further I want to put my fully fled side
tracker consider hitting the join button
there are links to all of our other
little bits like Sidetrack site where
I'm going to be talking about your
comments on
um watch the gate episode
um so please go over and subscribe there
too
as always please stay safe I'll see you
next time
[Music]